Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha
the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Are you going to translate that for us?
Oh, okay.
So I'm going to start off with just a little
talk about uh the buddha and war so the first is to you know make a distinction between pacifism and uh non-violence so pacifism wait wait wait wait sorry and
non-violence so pacifism is an ideology and ideologies like communism and neoliberalism always work on some sort of idea of how things ought to be
And therefore, they lose connection with what's actually happening.
And as Marx
said about capitalism it has the seeds of its own destruction so you can say that of any ideology non-violence is an attitude it's a way of relating to all beings
While non-violence is an attitude, a way of relating to all beings.
There are various stories that have been told about the Buddha who came into contact with war.
The first one is an argument between the Sakians, his own people, and the people on the other side of the river, the Coleans.
and this argument over water rights was moving towards a war between the two tribes.
So the Buddha
heard about it maybe, but he went up there to try and help with the rights of the water.
And he basically asked them what was more precious, the water in the river or the blood in their veins?
Basically he asked them what was more precious, the water in the river or the blood in their veins.
So this made them decide to sit around a table to discuss
Now there was a more serious situation with Viduddha Bhat.
He was the son of Pasenadi and Pasenadi was a very committed supporter of the Buddha.
the Vidudaba wanted to marry into the Sakya.
The Sakyas were already vassals to the king of Kosala.
They were subjects.
And so he married one of the Sakyan princesses.
E quindi costui sposò una delle principesse dei Sacchia.
However, he came to know that in fact she wasn't a princess at all, but belonged to the lowest of all the castes.
Però poi a un certo punto scoprì che non si trattava affatto di una principessa, ma invece apparteneva a una delle caste inferiori.
Well, he was very angry, so he got his army together to go and destroy the Sakians.
He had his elephants and his cavalry, his chariots and his infantry.
When the Buddha heard this, he went to see him.
Now, we don't know what the Buddha said to him, but I would think it was along the lines of this is not going to create good karma for you.
So Viduddha took his advice and went home.
No sooner had he got home than he got angry again and got back on his elephant.
Non feci in tempo a tornare a casa che subito si arrabbiò nuovamente e risalì sui suoi elefanti.
So the Buddha appeared again and seemed to have convinced him to turn back.
Il Buddha comparve nuovamente e sembra che lo abbia convinto a tornare indietro.
As soon as he got back he got angry and he got back on his elephant.
Appena tornò a casa si arrabbiò nuovamente e risalì sull'elefante.
Again the Buddha came and again convinced him that this was not a good idea so he went back home.
Di nuovo la stessa cosa comparvi il bunda che lo convinse a tornare a casa che non era affatto una buona idea.
But unfortunately as soon as he got home he got angry and he got back on his elephant.
Appena tornò a casa si arrabbiò nuovamente e risali sugli elefanti.
This time, when they asked the Buddha to go again, he said, it's not going to work, he's committed.
So it would seem that he destroyed the capital of the Sakyas, Kapilavatthu.
Probably the Sakians ran off into the jungle for a while and they set up another capital city.
Seemingly, you can actually visit them.
One is in India and one is in Nepal.
The final example is to do with Ajatasattu.
Ajatasattu was the son of Bimbisara, the king of Magadha.
In the same way, Bimbisara had been a very good supporter of the Buddha, but his son just didn't have the same commitment.
In fact, Ajatasattu starved his poor old father to death.
He locked him in a little room, which they say you can still see in Rajgir.
Yeah, Rajgir.
It was a small building, excuse me, away from the palace.
Now, he wanted to conquer the Vajji Confederacy.
And the peculiar thing is that he sent his chief minister to ask the Buddha whether it was the best time to do so.
Now the Buddha, of course, won't tell anybody what to do.
All he does is point to principles and you are left to make the decision.
Now what he did was to describe the qualities of a strong community.
The qualities that keep a community strong.
And he was really talking about the monastics, the monks and nuns.
So Vassacaro and the King presumed that he was hinting that the Vagis were a strong people.
So he didn't attack them.
He sent in the CIA and in order to bribe and set one people against another
Ah, per cercare di pagarli con una moneta facendo in modo che entrassero in conflitto l'uno contro gli altri.
And when the time was right, he went in with his army to keep the peace.
Ah, e al momento opportuno entrò con tutto il suo esercito per riportare la pace che, peraltro, la guerra che aveva lui stesso procurato.
So, some writers say that the Buddha would support a defensive war.
But there's no indication in the scriptures that he either encouraged or discouraged anybody from war as such.
He was in a tricky position because the monks and nuns had spread throughout the whole of North India.
because the monks and nuns had spread throughout northern India.
If he had supported one king against the other, then you can imagine all the monks and nuns in the territory of the king he did not support would be kicked out.
The problem was that if he had supported
Now, this does make the Buddha sound, it does sound a little cynical of the Buddha.
But he was grounded in reality, realpolitik,
So there must have been some concern about the monks and nuns.
But I think the main thing is that he never told people what to do.
He was only concerned with getting across those principles that are necessary to bring suffering to an end.
What really interested him was to communicate those principles that could allow suffering to cease.
So, I can only presume that when the question of war came up, it was always pointing to that person and saying, if you go to war, you will create bad karma for yourself.
Because it's very difficult to kill another human being unless you have aversion in the heart.
Now we have the example of the Shaolin Kung Fu monks in China.
We have the example of the Shaolin monks, monks who practice Kung Fu in China.
What happened in China was that if an emperor did not love the monks, the Buddhists would persecute them, while perhaps a subsequent sovereign
So the Shaolin monks began to develop a form of fighting which was defensive, not to be overcome by aversion towards the enemy.
so that they could not be overwhelmed by adversity towards the enemy.
This type of ethics was then passed on to Japan by China and became part of the samurai code.
So the samurai were warriors.
And there is a story where a samurai had beaten his opponent, had lifted the sword to cut him in two and then walked away.
Sorry, I didn't get that.
What happened?
There was a point where a samurai defeated his opponent.
He had raised his sword to cut him in two, but then walked away.
And when they asked him why he'd walked away, he said, I was angry.
So when it comes to considering what our personal relationship is to war, remember that
that is our personal relationship to war it's not the buddha's and all the buddha would say to you if you were to ask him is you know can you kill somebody without aversion in your heart
And if you do kill someone with aversion in your heart, then that will bring unwholesome results for yourself.
So, of course, this is not a very straightforward decision between black and white.
If you're defending your family, defending the country, then of course that particular motivation may be greater than getting rid of the aversion in your heart.
Certainly, if you find yourself having to defend your family or your country,
And it's left to the individual to decide how they feel or understand they ought to behave.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
that I have not caused greater confusion and that by careful decision-making you will find your way to complete liberation from suffering.
Very good.